what is that preferred rhythm from what
you've seen is it pulses of conflict not
too soon but don't have too much
conflict for too long give them a break
for a second I mean I don't know if
there's that's their standard a good
thing but I think you need the first act
has to deliver the dramatic question you
know ideally there is a protagonist who
has a very clear objective ideally there
are stakes so there are consequences if
that protagonist doesn't succeed and the
higher those stakes the more dramatic
the story
ideally there is a scene and there's a
whole book save the cat but it's kind of
based on that ideally you have given the
audience a reason to side with that
protagonist which a lot of movies and
scripts leave out completely which is
amazing to me because it's one of the
main ingredients why would I as an
audience care if that character sees his
father before he dies you know there
must be something that shows me a
humanity inside of that character it can
be a bad bad mafia serial killer
whatever guy but something that I can
relate to where we share our humanity in
that moment so that he becomes the
vehicle for me to discover things about
myself in the end I think that's the
secret that every audience it's a very
that's a very selfish process I think
every audience really comes to the
theater to learn something about
themselves and not about Oklahoma or
space or whatever but about their
emotions in that moment but that only
works if you can create a connection
between the protagonist and the audience
earlier so that would probably be the
formula I'm looking for is there a
connection is there a clear want which
leads to the dramatic question which is
will this protagonist successfully save
the love of his life whatever whatever
and then you go into the second act
where there are where you have to look
at the conflicts is there enough he is
what he steps he is doing are they
escalating in a way that at the same
time is believable but also doesn't need
too much patience customer in real life
you would probably first phone his
grandmother and then he would go we
don't want to sit through all that we
want the condensed version we want the
fake version but we wanted to feel
emotionally real which is a hard thing
to achieve but it was something that you
can very clearly track throughout a
second action I think and the first half
of the second act normally traditionally
is called like the fun and games part
which is where most the see of the
scenes that you see in a trailer are in
the first half of the second act where
the promise of the movie the reason why
people came is to see those scenes you
know it's like oh there's a man that
talks to his snake Mel Mel Gibson with
this beaver and Jodie Foster's movie you
know that would be the first half of the
second act where we kind of have a
little bit of time the clock is ticking
quite as fast yet and then most of the
time the mid-point halfway through the
story is a more fundamental twist to the
whole story it turns out the beaver is
real or it has whatever whatever you
know can actually talk of something that
changes our whole look on the story in
the direction of the story which i think
is super important because otherwise the
second act gets very long like if it's
only a one directional thing which
exists of course it is it exists
successfully but it's very hard to
execute to keep the audience's attention
without something that in the middle
kind of breaks the movie up and gives it
a whole different direction and a lot of
time like in a spy movie it would be our
protagonist finds out that the agency he
is working for us actually the bad guys
bubble bubble so suddenly it's or in Mad
Max it's when they've been driving into
that one direction and now therefore
chief whatever they need to achieve
another literally turning around coming
back that would be kind of the midpoint
then the stakes have to be raised in the
second half of the second act and lead
the major confrontation then if you go
by the hero's journey which I believe in
or not Joseph Campbell and all that kind
of stuff
there is the major confrontation it
looks like the hero is going to die he
metaphorically dies sheds his old ego
will learn something about himself that
he didn't know before there's most of
the time painful and that enables him
because he doesn't break in that moment
he almost breaks you get him to the
breaking point and you can see that in
almost every movie that that is being
done because we need to really break a
character to see what he's made of
right if you never challenge a character
you don't know what he really has inside
of so you almost break him and in that
process of staring death in the face
metaphorically or that obviously in a
romantic comedy it would be the girl is
dating another guy you know it doesn't
have to be death literally but it's the
death of that so now our protagonist
learns something about himself that was
in his flights but that he didn't know
before which now enables him to be to
use that as a tool to change
that's why character arcs and
development are so important
become a different person and that
enables him to achieve the goal that he
hadn't been able to achieve before
nowhere in the third act where most of
the time he has to defend where he's
where he is challenged by the
antagonistic force that he's been
battling throughout the second act one
last time and that's where the big
dragon or Sauron or whatever we know
rears his head for the first time a text
and that he has to prove that the change
that he just went through is a permanent
one that can be challenged and he won
and will still survive with his old ego
end of story
so there will be at least the there's
the mythology that thousands of years
old you know paradigm that stories are
building you can go away from that
paradigm as much as you want but I think
it helps to know that that is what
audiences intuitively are expecting and
someone who does that really great is
Tarantino like I don't think there's
anyone who knows this story structure
better and messes with it and messes
with your expectation which is great but
it's different from no
and just writing something into the blue
and then wondering why people don't
identify with the characters or aren't
hooked to certain development or
something like that so that would be my
my formula structure that I can if I'm
if I'm reading it and I'm engrossed then
it doesn't matter you know if it's a
three-act structure or whatever but if I
feel like my attention kind of drifts
and I don't really care most of the time
the answer is in that structure that
somehow doesn't deliver what it needs to
deliver
you